Michelle was also having a spirited time
with the cast of on the faces of sex
armie hammer Felicity Jones and Justin
throw but for Justin there seemed to be
one very important family member missing
where's Connor
that would be kuma Justin's rescue dog
that photobombed our interview in July
this round tables with the cast up on
the basis of sex where Felicity plays a
young Ruth Bader Ginsburg get your
emotions in check you first the actors
got to meet the iconic Supreme Court
justice at her home she was just show me
they're just very welcoming and couldn't
take a rise up on me I'm sure I just
think she you know she's so petite
probably just looking up to someone like
she seemed to know yes what did she say
of course Ginsburg has been hilariously
parodied by Kate McKinnon on SNL and did
this work out with Stephen Colbert I
would just do her work out exactly like
he did I mean because clearly is working
really well for her but last month
Ginsburg was briefly hospitalized after
fracturing three ribs in a fall leading
to this means I've got more ribs
speaking of fun justin's in the midst of
a reimagining of the classic Lady and
the [ __ ]
he's the [ __ ] Tessa Thompson his lady I
was in London with Tessa recording
bringing each other to tears I
understand that the spaghetti scene is
there
[Music]
[Applause]